bien mes chers collègues on va entamer
parce que il y a pas mal d'activités en
séance et président buffet doit nous
quitter puisqu'il sera au banc tout à
l'heure
mes chers collègues donc nous sommes
heureux de recevoir aujourd'hui devant
deux commissions du scénario celle des
lois et celle des affaires européennes
Mathias guillaumard juge français à la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
c'est un plaisir de vous revoir après
notre entrevue en novembre 2021
Strasbourg monsieur le juge et
d'ailleurs aussi en novembre 2022 avec
le président buffet dans le président
dans le bureau du président Larcher avec
votre nouvelle présidente en marge d'une
rencontre avec les élus locaux que notre
commission consultée alors sur leurs
attentes concernant l'avenir de l'Europe
la mission de la Cour de Strasbourg et
d'assurer l'application de la Convention
de sauvegarde des droits de l'homme et
des libertés fondamentales un traité qui
a été signé en 1950 par les États
membres du Conseil de l'Europe et non
par les États membres de l'Union
européenne même s'il en appelle
communément la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme
cette convention assortie de ces
protocoles additionnels vise à garantir
le respect des libertés fondamentales
considérés comme un socle de la justice
et de la paix dans le monde la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a pour
mission d'assurer la bonne application
de ces textes dont peuvent se prévaloir
non seulement les ressortissants des
étapes partie à la Convention mais
encore toute personne relevant de leur
juridiction la cour dispose toutefois
d'une compétence subsidiaire en matière
de violation des droits de l'homme en
effet le requérant doit d'abord avoir
épuisé les voies de recours interne de
son état pour engager un recours devant
cette juridiction supradationale en 70
ans des questions nouvelles ont émergé à
la faveur des évolutions technologiques
ou géopolitiques et les requêtes devant
la Cour se sont multipliées par sa
jurisprudence la Cour permet à la
Convention d'évoluer pour répondre à ces
nouveaux défis en votre qualité de juge
français à la cour vous participez donc
à cette interprétation au même titre que
les 45 un autre juges un par État partie
qui ont tous été comme vous élus pour 9
ans par l'Assemblée parlementaire du
Conseil de l'Europe sur une liste de
trois candidats présentés par chaque
État partie
même si vous ne représentez pas la
France vous êtes en position d'éclairer
la course sur la marge d'appréciation
nationale qui a lui laisse comme à
chaque État partie
nous serions donc particulièrement
intéressés de recueillir votre analyse
sur les critiques que l'on peut entendre
en France sur les jugements de la Cour
dont il n'est pas possible de faire
appel et qui sont parfois accusés de ne
pas prendre suffisamment en compte
certains enjeux de sécurité nationale ou
de souveraineté ou encore de pratiquer
le deux poids de mesure certains états
consentant des efforts pour se conformer
aux arrêts de la cour quand d'autres
négligent leur exécution en toute
impunité je laisse la parole au
président buffet et après vous vous
entendrons avec plaisir merci Monsieur
président
mon propos est très complémentaire
j'espère en tout cas ce que vient de
dire le président rappin au-delà du fait
que nous heureux de nous accueillir au
Sénat pour cette audition au sein de ces
deux commissions
nous avons en tête les uns et les autres
que la jurisprudence de la Cour très
développée
diront est importante pour nous certains
diront même qu'elle est très RA mais
nous entreprenons acte compte tenu de
l'appartenance de notre pays d'ailleurs
au Conseil de l'Europe et des valeurs
juridique de la Convention européenne de
sauvegarde des droits de l'homme et des
libertés fondamentales dans notre monde
juridique nationale la joie de la Cour
de Strasbourg et chacun le sait ici nous
le disons souvent
s'impose à nous dans nos fonctions
législateurs
parfois ça fait un peu réagir mais en
tous les cas nous veillons à ce que cela
soit parfaitement respecté il faut ainsi
lever certains malentendus et le premier
étant peut-être que la France fait
certes l'objet de condamnation prononcé
par la Cour il n'est pas question de le
nier mais qu'elle est sans doute pas la
pire des élèves des états partis à la
Convention peut-être pourrez-vous nous
le confirmer en tous les cas c'est un
propos qui avait été esquissé à
l'occasion de la rencontre que nous
avions eu au mois de novembre dernier
avec la présidente à laquelle le
président rappin faisait référence tout
à l'heure l'un des aspects les plus
intéressants et sans doute les plus
structurants de la jurisprudence de la
Cour est à mon sens la marge de manœuvre
laissée aux États
et on le sait pas suffisamment laissé
aux États membres contenus de leur
propre spécificités juridiques ou
culturelles pour satisfaire aux
prescriptions de la Convention
européenne
peut-être pourriez-vous expliciter
davantage devant nous en quoi cette
marge d'appréciation
consiste en réalité de façon effective
elle permettra de mieux comprendre et de
sortir un peu des lieux communs de la
discussion ou des déclarations de façon
plus précise je souhaiterais également
vous interroger sur la portée de
certains arrêts la cour dans deux
domaines qui pour la commission des lois
en tous les cas mais imagine bien pour
l'ensemble des collègues et pour le
Sénat sont importants d'abord l'arrêt du
14 septembre 2022
HF et autres contre la France sur le
retour des djihadistes détenus au Levant
et ce qu'il implique réellement pour le
gouvernement français cela encore fait
l'objet il y a peu de temps de questions
gouvernement dans le cas de nos
questions d'actualité je crois que la
semaine dernière
dans certains
auditions donc c'est un point important
pour bien comprendre quels sont
finalement les obligations du
gouvernement et puis l'équilibre
chercher par la course sur les
interceptions de sécurité notamment
après les arrêts Big Brother watch de
mai 2021 aussi un sujet pour nous qui
comptent beaucoup qui intéresse souvent
la délégation parlementaire enseignement
mais qui est véritablement un sujet
d'importance à la fois pour la sécurité
de notre pays les conditions de travail
de nos propres services et donc voilà
c'est un point qui nous a beaucoup
interrogé et pour ne pas dire beaucoup
inquiéter voilà ce que simplement les
quelques propos que je souhaitais tenir
et maintenant je compte le président que
nous laissons la parole à Monsieur
guillaumard pour
Messieurs les Présidents pour vos mots
d'accueil et pour votre invitation à
venir présenter un certain nombre
d'éléments relatifs à la Cour européenne
et à sa jurisprudence et aussi
répondre dans la seule réserve de mon
devoir déontologique
tenant à certaines affaires pendantes
aux questions que chacune ou chacun
voudrait me poser je suis à votre
disposition je suis venu précisément
pour échanger et je vous en remercie et
je me réjouis aussi qu'une délégation du
Sénat Vienne au mois de mars à la cour
pour poursuivre les échanges je vous
l'ai dit ce que la présidente tolérique
qui est entrée en fonction la première
femme présidente de la Cour européenne
de droit l'homme qui est la juge élue au
titre de l'Irlande est venue dire au
président Larcher lorsque je vais
l'accompagner votre présence messieurs
c'est que
notre cours
extrêmement soucieuse du respect des
autorités nationales et dans les
autorités nationales au premier rang
nous plaçons les parlements
il y a cette architecture particulière
du Conseil de l'Europe avec l'Assemblée
parlementaire au siège des délégations
il y a vous y avez fait allusion
monsieur le Président cette
particularité que nous sommes à collège
du juge élu ce qui nous donne une
légitimité indirecte mais certaines et
qui nous oblige aussi et dans notre jeu
japonaise cette attention au Parlement
se traduit par une notion très anglaise
très britannique de déférence nous
utilisons souvent cette ce terme ce
n'est pas très familier en France en
tout cas pour une juridiction de
l'utiliser mais nous utilisons toujours
ce terme de déférence qui signifie à la
fois la prise en considération du rôle
et le respect du rôle particulier lié au
législateur de chaque chacun des États
46 états du Conseil de l'Europe
et donc je suis très heureux d'avoir
l'occasion de discuter de dire je pense
en quelques minutes simplement quelques
éléments généraux pour pouvoir ensuite
essayer de répondre à vos à vos
questions je voudrais témoigner de trois
choses c'est je vais essayer d'être
le plus direct possible pour satisfaire
vos attentes de trois choses qui me
semblent nécessaires à bien comprendre
pour
appréhender de la façon la plus exacte
possible le rôle de la Cour et la portée
de prudence vous y avez fait allusion la
cour est critiquée elle est critiquée
dans un nombre croissant d'État quel que
soit d'ailleurs le modèle juridique
auquel
ils appartiennent et parfois
c'est critiques sont plus que légitimes
nous les prenons en compte nous en nous
essayons d'en tirer les conséquences qui
doivent y être attachées mais parfois le
reposent sur des malentendus dès
quiproquos ou des préjugés et alors je
crois que notre rôle c'est faire de la
pédagogie de venir expliquer ce que nous
faisons vraiment et comment nous
fonctionnons réellement la première
chose que je voulais dire
cette pour répondre directement à votre
question sur la France est-elle souvent
condamnée ou non je voudrais redire très
simplement ici que ce qu'on entend
parfois être parfaitement inexact la
France est très peu souvent condamnée
d'abord la France est peu pourvoyeuse de
faire
alors depuis l'expulsion de la Russie
nous avons
placé sous la juridiction des 46 États
membres un peu plus de 700 millions de
personnes le nombre moyen de requêtes
portées devant la Cour par habitant et
de 0,50 un peu plus 0,53 en France c'est
011 c'est à dire que la France envoie
par habitant 5 fois moins de requête que
la moyenne des 46 états c'est le signe
l'un des premiers signes du bon
fonctionnement n'a pas judiciaire
français moi je suis issu du Conseil
d'État où j'ai siéger pendant 25 ans et
je peux témoigner comme un ancien acteur
juge interne on dit à la cour que nous
connaissons et nous appliquons la
Convention européenne et je peux
témoigner que l'ordre judiciaire fait de
même donc
cela d'abord le signe de la bonne santé
en termes fonctionnel de l'appareil
judiciaire français et l'ensemble de ces
affaires françaises
pas seulement en proportion par habitant
aboutir un volume tout à fait
raisonnable de requêtes nous avons
aujourd'hui un nombre trop élevé
d'affaires pendantes devant la cour tout
pour tous les pays confondus nous sommes
à presque 75 000 affaires
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup et il faut
savoir que c'est même fait de la place
parce que je me suis un peu étalé
excusez-moi mais sur ces 75 000 affaires
5 pays représentent les trois quarts du
stock la Russie pour les affaires qui
étaient encore
jusqu'au 16 septembre c'est pour presque
17000 l'Ukraine plus de 10000 la
Roumanie 6000 à peu près et d'Italie
3700 j'ai gardé la Turquie qui est pour
la femme même si c'est le premier
pouvoir du stock 20 000 affaires turc en
stock donc plus de la moitié consécutive
à des faits postérieurs à 2016 donc un
énorme stock c'est vrai 75000 affaires
mais cinq pays en constituent les trois
cas la France a aujourd'hui à l'heure où
je vous parle moins de 600 affaires en
stock sur 75000 c'est peu et l'année
dernière sur l'ensemble des affaires
réglées judiciairement par la Cour
concernant la France le taux de
condamnation a été inférieur à 1%
l'année dernière nous avons jugé j'ai
les chiffres presque
parfaitement à jour mais nous avons
toujours à peu près on va dire des
volumes constants c'est assez
intéressant nous sommes toujours entre
600 et 700 à faire en stock nous sommes
toujours avec dans les affaires qui
rentrent un tiers qui est aiguillé vers
le juge unique c'est-à-dire des rejets
manifestes deux tiers vers les
formations collégiales à 3 7 ou 17 juges
et nous avons des volumes à peu près qui
tournent autour de 700 affaires
maintenant que nous jugeons
judiciairement pour la France et bien
l'un des dernières nous sommes même
montés à 750 affaires pour la France et
bien il faut savoir qu'en moyenne depuis
15 ans c'est 2% des affaires françaises
qui donnent lieu à un constat de
violation seulement et l'année dernière
en 2021 pour les affaires de 2001
c'était moins de 20%. et donc
la première chose que je dis peu
d'affaires et encore moins en proportion
c'est vraiment tout à fait marginal de
condamnation ce qui est un deuxième
signe de la bonne santé si je peux dire
de l'appareil juridictionnelle française
et de la du fait que notre ordre
juridique qu'il s'agisse de la loi que
vous adoptez de son application que
l'administration prend en charge ou de
son contrôle que les juges internes
effectués
l'ordre juridique interne est compatible
avec les exigences de la Convention il
n'y a pas de bouleversement d'impact
absolument considérable que notre
jurisprudence à la Cour européenne
entraînerait alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
un ressenti il y a un ressenti qui est
différent d'en avaient parlé avec le
président de l'archet ce ressenti il
s'explique il est presque normal c'est
que la pointe de l'iceberg c'est la plus
visible c'est la plus sensible l'année
dernière nous avons eu 19 arrêt de
compte de violation 19 violations
constatées pour la France
c'est peu mais quand vous avez parlé de
l'affaire h de grandes chambres sur les
rapatriments des enfants ne restent de
la Syrie si jamais sur des questions
anodines vous avez deux types de
violations en réalité ce qu'on peut
appeler les violations micro c'est à
dire c'est vraiment un cas d'espèces une
situation particulière très spécifique
et là le compte ne s'y trouve pas
regarde d'un des droits protégés et puis
vous avez des violations dont la pacte
et plus structurels qui ont qui portent
des enjeux plus systémiques et à ce
moment là évidemment la visibilité d'une
condamnation est à proportion de la
lourdeur des enjeux sur laquelle elle
porte et c'est ça qui explique le
ressenti mais je pourrais vous donner
autant d'exemples sinon plus d'arrêt qui
viennent conforter lors de juridique
français que d'arrêt qui viennent
constater une incompatibilité et je peux
donner quelques exemples concrets
récents
il faut bien comprendre aussi que vous
avez parlé la subsidiarité de la marge
nationale d'appréciation c'est un aimant
essentiel de notre positionnement
vis-à-vis des états c'est la deuxième
série d'observation que je voulais faire
mais je voudrais finir sur ma première
avec quelques exemples oui HF vous en
avez parlé une affaire de grandes
chambres 17 juge la formation la plus
solennelle qui constate une violation
procédurale de l'article 3 par l'art de
du protocole 4 sur le droit des
ressortissants de retourner dans leur
pays
ça veut dire précisément
que il y a eu dans le constat effectué
par la Cour
la considération qu'en termes de
garantie procédurale le compte n'y était
pas suffisamment au regard des exigences
de la convention mais nous avons bien
pris le soin dans cet arrêt de dire deux
choses premièrement il n'y a pas dans la
convention de droit général ou
rapatriement et nous avons inexiste pas
de droit général et absolue au
rapatriement ensuite nous avons dit il
n'y a donc pas d'obligation de résultats
et de nombreux États européens étaient
intervenus à la procédure nous jugeons
une affaire concernant un état mais avec
la règle du non double standard la
solution que nous rando s'applique dans
les 46 états
et ce que nous avons dit c'était la
lumière aussi des observations que
d'autres États étaient venus porter à
l'appui de la défense française et nous
avons eu cette échelle européenne à
l'esprit comme nous l'avons toujours
quand nous rendons une affaire mais
celle-ci tout particulièrement donc il
n'y a pas d'obligation de résultats il y
a une obligation de moyens pour garantir
en cas de refus de rapatriement
contre le risque d'arbitraire c'est une
notion que nous manions elle est
habituelle nous voulons éviter et c'est
l'une des caractéristiques de l'État de
droit que des décisions susceptibles de
porter atteintes à des droits
fondamentaux soit empreinte d'arbitraire
c'est-à-dire que ici ce qui a été je
vous répond très précisément relever
comme insuffisant c'est le fait que le
refus opposé aux demandes des familles
n'étaient pas motivés elle ne savait pas
pourquoi nous avons dit qu'il fallait
une motivation sommaire dans le respect
des secrets protégés par la loi mais au
moins quelque chose
et qu'il n'y avait pas de contrôle
juridictionnel sur ces refus et nous
avons d'ailleurs dit parce que ça c'est
notre joli prudence il suffit d'un
contrôle exercé par un organe
indépendant qui n'est pas nécessairement
juridiction en France ce serait une
juridiction bien sûr ce qui s'était
passé dans ces affaires c'est que tant
le juge administratif que le juge
initial avait opposer la théorie des
actes de gouvernement déclinant leur
compétences pour connaître une question
qui touchette selon eux à la conduite et
relation internationales de la France et
bien nous avons dit là il y a une
insuffisance en termes de garantie
procédurale qui entraîne un constat de
violation pour l'exécution
correct de cet arrêt je ne peux pas dire
grand-chose
d'autres je ne peux rien dire d'autre
même que ce qu'il y a dans l'arrêt car
vous le savez c'est le Comité des
Ministres organes politiques qui est
chargé de la surveillance de l'exécution
de l'arrêt mais je peux dire et redire
très clairement car il y a eu beaucoup
de choses un peu approximatif ce qu'il y
a dans la raie il y a simplement que
l'État français de la même manière que
d'autres États confrontaient la même
situation
doit prévoir maintenant une procédure
formalisant dans le respect des
exigences minimales que la Cour a défini
formalisant les motifs du refus et
prévoyant une un contrôle par un organe
indépendant
sur le bien fondé de ces refus mais nous
avons même écrit qu'il pouvait y avoir
des refus légitimes mais qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait que quelqu'un un organe
indépendant puisse contrôler la
légitimité de ce donc je suis très
précis là-dessus pas d'obligation de
résultat certainement pas une obligation
de moyens et nous faisons beaucoup de
violations procédurale parce que c'est
une manière je pense j'y reviendrai de
laisser la main aux États quand on donne
des lignes directrices en matière de
garantie de processuel ou procédural on
ne préoccupe pas le fond
car très souvent le fond nous lui disons
nous-mêmes nous ne sommes pas aptes à
décider à la place nous avons ce que
nous appelons le principe de non
substitution nous substituons pas notre
appréciation à celle des autorités
nationales alors effectivement il y a
cette affaire qui a entraîné une
condamnation il y en a d'autres si je si
je veux essayer de repérer quels sur
l'année qui vient de s'écouler les
facteurs explicatifs du nombre de
violations que nous avons prononcé
s'agissant de la France
je veux pas vous faire je vous rassure
le répertoire de 19 affaires mais il y a
ce que j'appelle des queues de comètes
nous avons fait plusieurs condamnations
par exemple pour l'absence du droit à
l'avocat en audition libre pourquoi
c'est une queue de comète parce que
malheureusement nous jugeons encore avec
un délai trop long aujourd'hui il doit
français s'est mis en accord comme pour
la garde à vue avec ses exigences des
droits de la défense droit de garder le
silence droit d'avocat mais nous avions
des vieilles affaires d'une époque
antérieure mais ça fait quand même une
violation nous avons eu des violations
aussi en ce qui concerne la question
migratoire une contentieux des étrangers
je veux en parler ici car souvent la
cour est attaquée sur ce contentieux là
en France il y a eu deux types de
violations la première concerne des
durées de rétention administrative que
nous avons jugé excessif pour les
mineurs et la seconde concerne là aussi
des violations procédurales sur le mode
d'évaluation du risque
encouru en cas de renvoi dans le pays de
destination par tel ou tel personne
expulsée et là nous avons notamment ça a
fait susciter un débat tout à fait
légitime et souhaitable des violations
concernant des ressortissants russes qui
avaient été
en russe et ce que nous avons dit en
d'ailleurs nous appuyant sur la chose
prenance de la Cour de Luxembourg et
celle du Conseil d'État c'est que dans
l'évaluation autorise
il fallait prendre en compte le fait que
les gens qui étaient une requérants les
gens dans la situation particulière
avaient été réfugiés c'était vu révoquer
le statut de réfugiés mais en fonction
de la gestion et de la conduction et du
Conseil d'État avec gardé la qualité
d'un sujet d'une distinction un peu
subtile mais
la qualité existe toujours malgré les
statues la révocation du statut permet
l'éloignement mais la qualité subsiste
et nous nous avons dit il faut tenir
compte de ce critères dans l'évaluation
de risque ça ne veut pas dire et là
aussi c'est une violation procédurale
que une fois l'évaluation reprise au
terme du nouvel examen complet il y
aurait une impossibilité d'éloigner et
je voudrais être précis là-dessus car
très souvent
j'ai vu dans la presse la cour empêche
la France tel autre pays ça peut être
d'éloigné de des terroristes ou des
personnes qui d'ailleurs souvent commis
des faits tout à fait répréhensible et
souvent condamné nous n'avons pas dit ça
nous avons dit
le mode dévaluation de risque n'est pas
satisfaisant regarde des exigences de la
convention alors maintenant je vous
avais dit nous avons jugé aussi beaucoup
d'affaires de non violations et je me
rappelle de l'entretien avec le
président Larcher qui l'avait dit vous
monsieur vous aviez dit la même chose
mais il y a les arêtes les affaires de
comité des décisions que nous rejetons à
trois juges comme
manifestement mal fondé c'est la
personne n'en parle elle passe sous les
radars
il faudrait en parler davantage alors je
viens vous en parler depuis deux ans
nous avons dû 50 à faire une
cinquantaine d'affaires en comité sur
des questions lourdes
et à chaque fois ce sont des rejets en
ce qui concerne des violences policières
dont nous avons jugé qu'elle n'était pas
excessive violence à léguer mais que la
réponse des forces de l'ordre était
proportionnées à la situation en ce qui
concerne là aussi des étrangers 4
affaires concernant des éloignements
forcés au regard de l'article 8 4 rejets
pour défaut manifeste de fondement du
grief alors quand je lis un article qui
dit l'article 8 appliqué par la Cour
empêche d'éloigner des étrangers ou
impose le regroupement familial je peux
venir avec des quatre arrêts et dire moi
j'ai eu quatre affaires depuis deux ans
pour la France 4 jeux
une expulsion de Cambronne si rejet je
pourrais je vais pas vous faire les 50
non plus mais ça c'est vrai qu'il y a
peut-être un déficit de communication
qui donne une vision déséquilibrée de ce
que nous jugeons et je terminerai avec
des arrêts de chambre où nous examinons
vraiment les mérites à 7 parfois après
une audience trois arrêts récents de la
fin 2022 du début 2023 viennent
illustrer ce que j'appelais le travail
confortatif que fait notre cours par
rapport aux droits français un arrêt
down qui concerne le contrôle du Conseil
d'État sur les procédures disciplinaires
en l'espèce un ambassadeur non violation
conformité aux exigences de l'article 6
des procédures et des choses pendantes
un arrêt très important pas jury contre
France rendu après une audience de
chambre s'agissant d'une assignation à
résidence prise pendant l'état d'urgence
poste 2015 non violation à l'unanimité
reconnaissance du caractère effectif du
resserrer liberté et caractère non fondé
du grief tiré d'une atteinte excessive à
la liberté d'aller venir et puisque vous
m'avez interpellé sur la marge
d'appréciation je vais passer parce que
je vais pas prendre trop de temps à ma
deuxième série de considération avec
l'affaire y contre France qui a été
rendu hier et qui concerne vous avez
peut-être entendu parler de cette
affaire qui est assez médiatique une
personne biologiquement intersexuée qui
avait demandé le changement sur son état
civil de sexe masculin qui lui avait été
attribué par section neutre non
violation
non violation avec justement cette
mobilisation de la marge nationale
d'appréciation qui montre bien que nous
intervenons à notre tour après
l'épuisement des voies de recours
interne c'est la subsidiarité
procédurale et à notre place dans le
respect des marges nationales
d'appréciation c'est-à-dire dans le
respect de ce que nous laissons
délibérément à la main des états là nous
avons fait une étude de droit comparé
il y a sur cette question du de la non
binarité et toute petite minorité d'État
en Europe qui a pris le le fait le choix
par la loi d'ailleurs de permettre un
tiers genre ou un absence de mention
genrée sur les actes d'état civil mais
c'est 7 sur 46 il n'y a pas de consensus
que nous appelons le consensus en
l'absence de consensus européen nous
nous sentons pas légitimes à imposer un
modèle qui ne recueille pas la sentiment
de la majorité des États et ce d'autant
plus que nous sommes dans des questions
sociétales
qui peuvent légitimement susciter des
controverses et là nous le disons
toujours c'est le législateur national
qui est légitime pour fixer le point
d'équilibre entre des situations qui
peuvent opposer un intérêt public
[Musique]
rédaction de la convention c'est
fascinant d'ailleurs ce qui est
fascinant c'est de voir que c'était la
France le Royaume-Uni et l'Italie
c'était il y a ceux qui venait de se
faire la guerre qui était les trois
frères de lance de cette construction du
Conseil de l'Europe assez d'accord et
c'était Pierre Henri de John qui est qui
a porté la plume en déclinant à
l'échelle européenne la Déclaration
universelle d'or René Cassin qui a eu
cette belle formule que je voudrais vous
livrer qui a dit pour nous les États
européens qui partageons ces idéaux de
paix de justice il s'agit d'éviter le
retour de l'épouvante
et c'est ça c'est l'idée on venait pas
là pour nier les biodiversités
politiques les biodiversité juridiques
au contraire notre convention prend
racine dans cette richesse qu'à la
variété des états des histoires des
peuples et des traditions juridiques
elle prend racine pour projeter
l'ensemble des États qui ont fait cette
signée ce pacte commun vers un horizon
partagé mais il s'agit pas de substituer
un modèle à 46 modèles c'est pour ça que
nous travaillons beaucoup et maintenant
avec la ratification du Protocole 15
principes de subsidiarité et la marge
d'appréciation sont dans le préambule de
la convention c'était des notions issues
de notre jurisprudence mais qui était
simplement le reflet de l'architecture
du dispositif créé maintenant il y a
plus de 70 ans alors la dernière série
de d'observation parce que je veux
laisser du temps en question
peut-être ne suis-je pas assez précis
j'en suis désolé mais j'aurai l'occasion
de revenir plus techniquement si vous le
souhaitez c'est la place de la France
dans ce dispositif et je voudrais venir
témoigner devant vous
de ce que je vis maintenant depuis près
de 3 ans avec
voilà je vous le dis en toute simplicité
beaucoup de satisfaction c'est de voir
que la France compte joue un rôle de
premier plan en Europe et que par sa
participation au dispositif du Conseil
de l'Europe elle rayonne elle fait
rayonner les valeurs de la France elle
fait rayonner le modèle français c'est
vrai que dans notre blogs de
constitutionnalité nous avons les mêmes
droits que dans la convention et donc il
n'y a pas de hiatus entre notre nos
droits fondamentaux conçus à la
française et ceux qui sont dans la
Convention il peut y avoir des questions
de réglage je veux pas dire que mais
c'est fondamentalement le même bloc de
de droit de droits de l'homme
ensuite le français est l'une des deux
langues de travail et pour la
francophonie c'est un forum essentiel de
promotion de notre langue et derrière
notre langue vous le savez de notre
culture et derrière notre culture de nos
valeurs et quand je vois et je délibère
avec les collègues de 45 états même si
dans ma chambre nous travaillons à 10
et je vois l'importance qu'ils accordent
à la France à la position que la France
prend sur telle ou tel sujet c'est un
forum pour porter aussi notre modèle et
je pense qu'il n'y a pas enfin comme ça
comme juge national vous avez eu les
mots très juste de dire je ne suis pas
l'ambassadeur ni l'avocat de la France
je suis élu au titre de la France ce qui
me donne deux obligations comme celles
qu'on mes collègues Xavier
c'est-à-dire de siéger dans les affaires
contre la France et je pourrais vous
expliquer pourquoi c'est fondamental que
le juge national fonde siège pardon dans
les états pas dans les litiges dirigés
contre son état
et ce faisant de faire comprendre les
tenants et les aboutissants d'une
affaire des subtilités ou les
difficultés du système juridique
l'ampleur des enjeux en cause la
sensibilité de tel ou telle affaire
et de permettre et je suis content quand
je juge une affaire ukrainienne je suis
dans la section qui juge l'Ukraine et je
suis le juge unique l'un des deux juges
uniques pour les affaires Ukrainiens je
suis content que mon collègue ukrainien
fasse de même pour nous expliquer les
ressorts des affaires ukrainiennes ou ma
collègue espagnole qui a désormais
rejoint la section 5 ou ma collègue de
la République tchèque ou le président de
la section qui est l'ancien président du
Conseil d'État du Luxembourg
nous avons besoin pour que cela
fonctionne correctement en connaissance
de cause de cette inputi vous me
permettez cet anglicisme de cet apport
du juge national et cet apport c'est pas
seulement sur le cas
c'est pour la Joseph prudence et je
terminerai par là en disant notre chose
prudence n'est pas le cheval de Troie de
telle ou tel modèle ce n'est pas le
cheval de droit du commonw ou du droit
continental c'est le véhicule c'est de
creuser dans lequel nous essayons de
trouver par un droit de 6 vulgarité le
dénominateur commun qui va exhauster les
systèmes juridique nationaux et ça c'est
important que chacun puisse dire son mot
chacun puisse apporter justement la
source du système dont il est issu parce
que quand je dis que la convention
s'enracine dans les états bien il faut
aller puiser justement dans ses racines
les inspirations nous ne sommes pas un
droit hors sol nous sommes un droit
constitué de ses sources-là multiples et
je pense que notre chose prenante
s'efforce d'être le fruit de ces
hybridations fécondes dans le respect de
la diversité des systèmes et de la place
que les autorités nationales première
garante du respect des droits
fondamentaux Parlement
exécutif juge interne
occupe et nous sommes évidemment très
soucieux de cette responsabilité
partagée pas de substitution pas
d'uniformisation un droit qui finalement
cherche du commun mais comme disait
Mireille delmasi pour qu'il y ait du
commun il faut qu'il y ait du différent
et bien justement qu'est-ce qui nous
rassemble dans le respect de nos
différences je vous remercie
bienvenue cher collègue vous avez
entendu le propos très clair qu'on a
déjà entendu avec le président buffet et
je vous laisse
éventuellement alors oui Jean-Yves
Lecomte qui fait partie des deux
commissions lui commission des lois et
commission des affaires européennes
Jean-Yves
oui merci
Monsieur jugé merci Monsieur les
présidents trois questions de ce général
et une sur le sujet actuel sur lequel
nous plonchons par rapport à la vision
de l'Union européenne à la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme quand
vous évoquez la place du juge national
dans les affaires qui touche un pays
donné comment un juge national peut
quand on assiste bon c'est peut-être
faisable comment votre collecture arrive
à être présent sur tant d'affaires
est-ce qu'il y a pas un paradoxe
deuxième question lorsque vous avez une
affaire qui a été jugée je pense
au à l'Asie le Rwanda pour les personnes
qui demandent l'asile en Grande-Bretagne
et qui est finalement
un point fort
d'une volonté politique dans un état
comment est-ce qu'on dépasse cette cette
difficulté parce que probablement voilà
il y a eu un jugement de la Cour sur ce
sujet il y a eu des réactions assez
vives de Grande-Bretagne est-ce que sur
ce sujet précis vous voyez une sortie et
ce que d'une manière générale quand
c'est un voilà un point un point
politique très dur entre voilà un pays
membres un pays un pays signataire et la
décision que vous avez prise comment on
en sort enfin
sur l'adhésion de l'Union européenne à
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
à la Convention européenne de droit de
l'homme c'est à la fois le respect du
Traité des traités de l'Union européenne
c'est aussi une valeur symbolique énorme
pour même si c'est quelque chose de
nouveau finalement parce que c'est pas
un état c'est voilà nouvelle espace une
nouvelle structure c'est la première que
ça se fait comment est-ce que
ce que vous vous partagez est-ce que il
faut ce qu'on fait se fait trop de ce
que l'Union européenne se fait trop de
de difficultés en prenant en compte
finalement la vie de la Cour de justice
de 2013
il est vrai que si un requérant va
attaquer l'Union européenne pour quelque
chose qui n'est pas de sa compétence
comment est-ce que vous allez traiter la
chose
est-ce que vous avez finalement
l'impression qu'il y a une valeur
ajoutée réelle
même si la valeur ajoutée symbolique je
crois qu'elle est tellement essentielle
que toute façon faut y aller mais ce
qu'il y a vraiment une Val de valeur
ajoutée réelle sur quel type d'affaires
est-ce qu'on se fait finalement on se
complique la vie en essayant de répondre
à toutes les objections de la cgios
comment est-ce que vous percevez les
choses parce que on peut aussi
considérer que une fois que que tout à
fait qui
relève d'un État membre pourrait aussi
relever de l'Union ou en tout cas le
requérant pourrait le considérer donc
comment est-ce qu'on traite ça
merci beaucoup je vais répondre aux
trois questions mais forcer de répondre
et pour la dernière ça sera juste
quelques éléments de réponse pour la
première merci beaucoup parce que ça me
permet d'affiner ce que j'ai dit à
l'instant je n'ai pas tout dit et je
complète nous ne pouvons pas être juges
unique concernant notre pays donc c'est
pour ça que moi je suis judique sur les
affaires de canne parce que ce sont des
rejets forcément en juge unique donc
nous ne sommes jamais le juge unique
pour notre pays donc nous avons à peu
près je voulais dit un tiers d'affaires
françaises qui me font rejetés chaque
année par le juge unique ça n'est pas
moi et pour ma collecture que c'est plus
qu'un tiers donc déjà elle n'a pas cette
charge-là et ensuite
il y a
une distinction à faire entre la
présence prévue dans le traité de plein
droit en chambre cette juge et en grande
chambre Ju juge national est de le droit
et s'il ne peut pas si j'ai il y a un
juge à doc je me déporte sur une
quinzaine d'affaires pendant compte tenu
de mes anciennes fonctions conseils
d'État il y aura un juge adopte qui est
représentera la France en comité c'est
une pratique ce n'est pas une obligation
et effectivement vous avez pas fait
raison pour ma collègue turque ou mon
collègue ukrainien ne peuvent pas si
j'ai dans toutes les affaires de comité
ou la France est en cause moi je peux
parce que j'ai le volume qui me permet
donc merci pour me donner l'occasion
d'apporter c'est précisions sur
l'affaire du Rwanda
oui c'est une affaire qui a suscité
beaucoup
de débats et de critiques au Royaume-Uni
il faut bien savoir que nous n'avons pas
jugé l'affaire nous avons il y a le juge
de permanence qui a pris une mesure
provisoire ça me permet de dire un mot
et merci aussi pour cette occasion sur
les mesures provisoires l'article 39 de
notre règlement nous permet dans
certaines hypothèses de
je l'ai une situation dans l'attente de
la
l'instruction et du Règlement au fond de
la serre si un dommage irréversible
si un dommage irréversible et
susceptible de se réaliser
dans l'affaire Vincent Lambert c'est ce
qui s'était passé
la Cour avait ordonné de suspendre
l'arrêt du traitement le temps de juger
et ensuite la course c'était avant que
j'arrive à Strasbourg la Cour avait jugé
non violation confirmant la position
retenue par le Conseil d'État ce qui
avait levé la mesure provisoire et donc
on était revenu à l'état de santé
c'est-à-dire l'interruption du
traitement pour le Rwanda il a été et ça
c'est facile à comprendre apprécié que
une fois que les gens seraient retournés
au Rwanda c'était le fait accompli donc
ce qu'a demandé le juge de permanence
c'est de ne pas mettre en oeuvre les
vols vers le Rwanda mais maintenant et
c'est à la cour de juger le plus vite
possible parce que nous avons des
processus d'accélération des affaires
qui ont fait l'objet d'un 39 de prendre
position sur le fond
et effectivement de deux choses l'une
soit comme
la formation du jugement considérera
qu'il y a une atteinte et à ce moment-là
la mesure 39
s'arrêtera avec le constat de violation
qui aura des effets plus durables et ça
sera Comité des Ministres qui prendra le
relais soit comme dans l'affaire Vincent
Lambert la formation de jugement
considérable grief après instruction au
fond n'est pas fondée et ça fera c'est
c'est la mesure 39 et ça rendra possible
l'exécution donc des fois la destination
du Rwanda donc
on peut discuter de la de la procédure
sur ces mesures provisoires et nous
avons d'ailleurs un groupe de travail
auquel je participe interne à la cour
pour améliorer les la procédure et
apporter des garanties supplémentaires
dans les 39 il faut dire qu'il y a il y
a plus de 39 qu'avant pour la France on
est toujours sur à peu près un grand
nombre
d'affaires de demandes entre 100 et 150
par avec un taux d'octroi de 10%
seulement
voilà pour le Rwanda alors pour le gros
chantier
je
vais être
je vais rester à ma place
c'est celle d'un juge concerné si la
décision se produit et je dis ma place
parce que ce sont les états ce sont les
négociateurs qui sont
là dans leur rôle et qui ont la
légitimité pour faire aboutir le
processus ça ne m'empêche pas de pouvoir
quand même vous dire des choses alors
d'abord d'un point de vue institutionnel
puis d'un point de vue personnel qui
n'engagera pas mon institution d'un
point de vue institutionnel la cohérence
entre les deux ordres juridiques de
l'Union européenne et de du Conseil de
l'Europe et de la convention est
indispensable mais nous n'avons
heureusement pas attendu
l'adhésion pour la construire nous
rencontrons chaque année et la Cour de
Luxembourg vient de passer une journée à
Strasbourg pour des séminaires de
travail nous avons échangé sur l'équité
en matière de procédure pénale c'était
très intéressant j'ai fait une co-
présentation avec l'avocat général
français Jean Richard Delatour sur nos
jurisprudences car nous sommes soucieux
d'échanger et faire en sorte qu'il y ait
les plus grandes convergences possibles
nous avons une jurisprudence qui a créé
ce qu'on appelle la présomption
Bosphorus c'est-à-dire la présomption
d'équivalence des protections quand la
Cour de justice a jugé ou quand un État
membre à jugé que le droit de l'Union
était respecté par une mesure nationale
il est présumé respecté La convention
européenne parce qu'il y a une
équivalence des protections entre les
deux autres juridiques donc ça fait
fonctionner le système donc
institutionnellement parlant autant
l'objectif de cohérence est absolument
indispensable autant je pense que nous
nous efforçons de l'atteindre avant même
l'adhésion
qu'est-ce qu'apporterait
institutionnellement parlant l'adhésion
une supervision externe celle exacée par
la Cour de Strasbourg sur des actes de
la propre à l'Union européenne qui sont
aujourd'hui ne font pas l'objet de
contrôle
donc il y aurait effectivement une
valeur ajoutée en termes de
justicebilité ça c'est institutionnel je
peux dire ça je pense on en a pas besoin
pour faire fonctionner les deux systèmes
en bonne harmonie mais ça apporterait un
plus à titre personnel et je le dis avec
donc la précaution de rappeler que le
langage pas ma mon institution je pense
comme vous qu'il y a un effet symbolique
très fort
parce que là l'Europe marche sur les
deux pieds ensemble je pense qu'il y a
effectivement à ce moment là
à envisager qu'un certain nombre de
d'actes et maintenant de l'Union
européenne puisse faire l'objet d'un
contrôle de la part de la cour je pense
par exemple à certains décisions de la
Commission en matière de concurrence qui
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas être attaqués
ni à Luxembourg ni dans les ordres
internes donc c'est vrai que je vois
très bien
qu'il y aurait des contrôles pourtant
sur des matières qui aujourd'hui ne sont
pas contrôlées voilà et je pense que
d'une manière générale et ça c'est aussi
personnel ce que je vais vous dire il
faut pas avoir peur de l'empilement des
contrôles mais il faut s'efforcer que
l'empilement ne devienne pas
l'éparpillement et là on veut mettre de
la cohérence soit paradoxalement la
source de dysfonctionnement et de
dysharmonie donc je pense que si ça se
faisait il faudrait être extrêmement
vigilant
pour que ça se passe bien il y a des
lourds chantiers fonctionnels en termes
de
procédures à mettre en place nous
travaillons nous avons un groupe de
travail interne à la courge j'en fais
aussi partie qui anticipe pour anticiper
comment on ferait
il y a parce qu'il y aurait un juge et
lui au titre de l'Union européenne il y
a plein de choses comme ça mais nous ne
sommes pas légitimes à faire les
réglages nous sommes juste en interne
soucieux de pas être pris au dépourvu et
d'avoir les réponses le moment venu si
il arrive les réponses les plus
fonctionnelles et les plus les plus à
même de satisfaire la volonté politique
qui aura été manifestée au moment de
l'adhésion voilà donc
pour ne pas dire tout et son contraire
et et être clair j'espère je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui constituerait un
progrès mais qui appellerait beaucoup de
précautions beaucoup de vigilance de
part et d'autre et donc la capacité
d'inventer aussi une nouvelle modalités
mais
ça n'est pas
inatteignable
après il y a la question que vous
connaissez
mieux que moi de la question de
pesque qui n'est pas relève pas du
contrôle oui avant même d'instruire une
affaire il faut savoir si elle est elle
touche finalement l'Union européenne
dans son ensemble ou un État membre oui
oui sachant qu'en plus on peut avoir
voilà des des démarches un peu voilà
multipliées justement pour voir pour
aller à la pêche donc
il y a quand même ça ce qui veut dire
que la première chose que vous auriez à
faire dans chaque affaire c'est de
définir si effectivement c'est une
compétence de l'Union
ça fait partie des difficultés dont il
ne faut pas technique donc il ne faut
pas m'ignorer l'ampleur bien sûr et de
la même manière qu'il y a la question
d'épuisement des bonnes recours internes
donc ça serait compliqué que nous
venions juger une un acte de des
institutions de l'Union européenne sans
que la Cour de justice ne les ai jugé
avant parce que ça il est hors de
question alors là je ne parle donc
toujours comme mon nom mais hors de
question pour moi que le premier seul
juge soit la Cour de Strasbourg c'est
pas notre philosophie nous on est dans
la solidarité donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
des réglages techniques
de vous avoir en face de nous il paraît
viser la question de cours
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait que nous
modifions pour que le parquet français
soit considéré comme un juge indépendant
ça c'est ma première question la
deuxième c'est que le Conseil ces
dernières années à évoluer vis-à-vis de
conséquences attirer de d'erreur de
procédure et à autoriser alors ceux qui
sont de décision administrative
des procédures de régularisation est-ce
que
court permet aussi de passer par dessus
des horaires de procédure qu'elle ne
considère pas comme
déterminante enfin une curiosité
considérez-vous que la course serait
compétente
à l'encontre de décision
juridictionnelles prises par des
autorités de fait
occupants
un territoire
et le cas des républiques autoproclamés
en Ukraine et qui est membre du conseil
j'imagine que ces autorités qui sont en
place depuis 10 ans
ont des juridictions
elles ne relève pas de l'État ukrainien
légitime mais elle pèse sur des citoyens
qui sont restés en droit des citoyens
ukrainiens est-ce que à votre avis la
cour est compétente dans ce cas là
je commence par la plus redoutable c'est
la dernière question
je serai prudent parce que ça viendra
peut-être devant et puis comme je le
siège dans la section il y a l'Ukraine
je veux pas dire des choses qui me
conduiraient à devoir me récuser mais je
fais une réponse qui est en réalité très
résulte directement de la lecture du
traité notre compétence
elle est directement liée à deux choses
que l'État
dont on allaite qu'il est à l'origine du
fait générateur litigieux relève du
dispositif c'est pour ça que depuis le
16 septembre la Cour n'est plus
compétente pour les affaires qui
pourraient être survenus postérieurement
cette date pour la Russie mais le reste
pour le passé première condition
deuxième condition que l'État membre
donc à la fois membre du Conseil
européen ratifié la Convention et
juridiction sur le requérant donc il y a
donc notre compétence est deux fois
conditionnée subordonné au fait que
l'État joue le jeu
soit qui ne soit pas parti soit qu'il
est adhérer sans être parti soit qu'il
est adhéré qu'on n'est pas expulsé et
qu'il est juridiction et là vous avez un
double problème parce que vous avez le
problème
aux deux niveaux donc c'est voilà je
peux pas en dire plus mais voilà notre
compétence est subordonnée à ces deux
conditions sur le parquet alors c'est
une question en réalité qui n'alimente
pas de requête aujourd'hui contre la
France c'est très ancien l'affaire
moulin c'est la dernière affaire qui
concerne le parquet à la française et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que nous
n'avons jugé une question d'indépendance
du parquet qu'aux regardent de l'article
5 paragraphe 3 de la Convention c'est à
dire
le droit à la sûreté donc l'absence de
rétention arbitraire nous n'avons pas de
jurisprudence générale qui
disqualifierait
le système du pack à la française au
regard des exigences indépendance mais
il y a de la chose prudence qui alimente
un certain nombre de doutes ou de ou de
questions sur ce sujet
je peux pas dire plus parce que je pense
qu'un jour ou l'autre il y aura des
questions notamment en ce qui concerne
vous avez fait allusion aux
interceptions de sécurité mais si
certaines sont autorisés par le parquet
et vous savez que la Cour de Luxembourg
elle-même rendu des jours prudence qui
ne sont pas sans effet sur la conduite
d'un certain nombre de procédures tout
ça nous faisons parfaitement au courant
je rencontre d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
procureurs généraux de France au mois de
mai à Colmar à l'invitation du procureur
général près de la cour d'appel de
Colmar et ça fait partie aussi du
travail du juge national d'être au
contact des autorités nationales et
j'échangerais certainement à froid
jamais sur un dossier vous en doutez sur
ce type de de considération mais j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de discuter avec des
procureurs de la République de ces
questions là je suis prudent le moment
viendra peut-être un jour mais en tout
cas en l'état de la chose prudence il
n'y a pas de disqualification
structurelle du parti à la française
voilà ça c'est très important de le
rappeler ensuite la question de la
dantonisation comme on dit c'est-à-dire
la régularisation oui dans notre
prudence procédons de la sorte et
c'était vraiment l'esprit même de
largeur prudence de la cour c'est-à-dire
que nous ne considérons jamais que le
constat d'un vice de procédure envoie
monsieur le Président donner un instant
T sanctuarise la question et puis le
match je parlais de l'équité de la
procédure pénale nous avons depuis un
centre d'affaires Salle 12 contre
Turquie et notamment buzz contre
Belgique concernant le droit à l'avocat
mis en place que nous appelons le
contrôle de l'équité globale de la
procédure nous appréhendons la procédure
dans son ensemble nous regardons quelle
est si il y a une lacune
un vice de procédure si oui quel est son
ampleur et si oui est-ce qu'il a été
purgé compensé par la suite de la
procédure et nous sommes arrivés parfois
je parlais des auditions libres tout à
l'heure dans deux affaires nous avons
constaté une violation pour défaut
d'avocat parce que ça n'avait pas été
rattrapé et pas dans la troisième parce
que ça avait été régularisé par d'autres
moyens c'est à dire que nous avons
vraiment une appréhension d'ensemble et
c'est à la fin et c'est assez conforme à
notre notre façon de faire nous nous
jugons une situation nous ne jugeons pas
un acte nous ne jugeons pas une norme
c'est très différent du juge national de
ce point de vue là nous jugons les
effets produits dans une situation
certes par l'application d'une loi ou ou
par une décision de justice mais nous
jugeons la compatibilité des effets avec
nos exigences si bien que oui c'est tout
à fait dans notre logiciel d'avoir cette
plasticité cette capacité à régulariser
avec une approche très dynamique de ce
qui s'est passé donc non seulement
ça ne poserait pas de problème mais nous
le pratiquons nous le pratiquons depuis
depuis longtemps
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
monsieur le juge merci pour vous
vos propos passionnants sur le
fonctionnement de la Cour j'ai une
première question
sur l'influence du droit français est-ce
que c'est influence c'est quantifiable
en termes de pourcentage et
quels sont les autres droits qui qui
sont le plus le plus utilisé et puis une
seconde question sur
l'aspect pédagogique
l'acceptation des décisions c'est
important dans dans une dans une
démocratie
et
je vais illustrer cette cet aspect
par l'une des condamnations de la France
c'est à propos
de la rétention puis de l'expulsion de
mineurs comorien
à Mayotte la France a été condamnée
l'année dernière pour pour cela et dans
nos territoires reculés où nous avons
des pressions et notamment la pression
migratoire ces décisions de condamnation
ne sont pas très comprise sont même
peuvent être même prises pour la double
peine et ce qu'il n'y a pas un travail
pédagogique un travail d'explication
amener pour
mieux expliquer mieux faire comprendre
ces décisions de la Cour qui sont
parfaitement attendables dans le
standard
métropolitain par exemple mais compte de
ces particularités notamment à notre
mère et ce qui n'est pas un effort de
pédagogie et le cas échéant sous quelle
forme
merci beaucoup il y a des fautes
pédagogique constant et je pense qu'il y
a des efforts d'ailleurs dans tous les
domaines nous devons améliorer encore
nos méthodes de travail nous devons
diminuer les délais de jugement nous
devons nous nous efforçons de rédiger de
manière plus claire plus accessible et à
ce travail de pédagogie dont vous parlez
c'est tout à fait certain et parfois on
s'aperçoit et c'est dommage qu'un arène
n'a pas été bien compris et pourtant
c'était forcé d'être clair dans la dans
la rédaction dans le raisonnement et
parfois dans le mode d'emploi pour son
exécution que nous donnons sous nous
appelons des observations sous l'article
46 c'est-à-dire
lorsqu'il y a des mesures générales à
prendre je vais faire référence à une
affaire qui était rendue avant que
j'arrive à la cour qui a la régie MB
contrefrance sur les Condes conditions
de détention il y a eu des mesures
générales préconisées par la Cour dans
cet arrêt de condamnation et à la fin
après des décisions de la Cour de
cassation du QPC vous avez adopté la loi
du 8 avril 2021 créant une nouvelle voie
de recours donc oui toujours plus de
pédagogie sur cette affaire
et doit être plus ancienne que l'année
dernière parce que je n'ai pas eu
d'affaires d'expulsion depuis Mayotte
depuis que je suis à la cour et je
connais bien la situation mahoraise
c'est une des premières missions que
j'ai faite quand je suis arrivé au
Conseil d'État en 96 sur le statut de
Mayotte et on ne parlait pas encore de
départements
départementalisation mais on était loin
et il y a des affaires actuellement
pendant concernant Mayotte sur la
rétention
en zone d'attente
avec
consécutives aux décisions de des
Comores de refuser d'accueillir des des
bateaux pour les mineurs non accompagnés
donc il va y avoir des affaires je peux
juste dire que nous prenons en compte le
contexte nous faisons un contrôle incron
c'est ce que je disais pour commencer
c'est-à-dire c'est toujours un cas
particulier même si nous devons juger
des choses qu'il faut s'appliquer dans
46 états on part du cas et le cas il est
situé nous n'avons pas une conception du
droit théorique hors sol c'est toujours
dans un contexte et effectivement pour
ce que je connais de la situation
mahoraise elle n'est pas comparable à ce
qui se passe sur le territoire de la
métropole en termes de pression
migratoire de difficultés de maintien de
leur public de moyens disponibles à la
main de l'État alors ça c'est toujours
très intéressant mais déjà au Conseil
d'État je faisais le même exercice avec
mes collègues juge interne c'est que le
juge il doit doser
il doit doser les choses c'est-à-dire
que il y a le noyau dur des des droits
et leurs substances avec lesquelles on
ne peut pas transiger il y a le réalisme
aussi ça sert à rien d'imposer
des standards inatteignables c'est
presque contre-productif donc
oui croyez moi c'est tout à fait
toujours dans le contexte que nous
prenons les choses en considération je
vais vous donner un exemple qui concerne
l'Algérie nous avions une jurisprudence
où nous considérions régulièrement
constamment même que c'était pour des
personnes avec des profils terroristes
dangereux regardent de l'article 3 de
les renvoyer en Algérie et puis un jour
le gouvernement français est venu avec
des assurances diplomatiques données par
l'État algérien
avec une audience qui ont changé la
donne et qui ont montré que le contexte
que nous sommes dans le contexte avait
évolué de telle manière que la chose
prudence a changé et que nous avons dit
qu'il n'y avait pas de violation
d'article 3 dans une autre affaire à X +
c un Algérien vers l'Algérie c'est
toujours institut incompréto et c'est
aussi ça je crois la responsabilité de
la cour c'est de ne pas être hors-sol et
de s'enfermer dans des conceptions
purement abstraites sur la place une
influence du droit français elle n'est
pas quantifiable non c'est certain ce
que je peux dire qualitatifment c'est
que le fait de parler français
le droit est un acte de langage et faire
du droit en français ça n'est pas la
même chose que de faire du droit en
anglais je fais les deux je rédige des
arrêts en anglais je délibère en anglais
sur les affaires que j'ai rédigé en
anglais et pourquoi je fais ça je le dis
ici au soutien la francophonie parce que
depuis que je fais ça
et un nombre croissant de collègues qui
font l'effort de délibérer même s'ils
sont plus à l'aise en anglais en
français sur les affaires en français
et mais je vois bien ce que le la langue
dans laquelle on rédige implique
transporte sur les concepts les notions
la façon de raisonner d'articuler les
choses donc par ça par le français alors
oui ça je peux vous dire qu'on pèse
merci Dominique delaige
oui merci monsieur le Président
excusez-moi de revenir sur la réponse
que vous avez en partie
faite à notre collègue le compte sur
l'adhésion de l'Union
le CEDH bon on voit bien qu'on est dans
une passe je veux dire vous dites on ne
peut pas juger non pas vocation à juger
en premier instant et la Cour de justice
européenne n'est pas compétente en
matière de politique de sécurité de
défense comment on sort de cet impasse
ça veut dire que vous renoncez à juger
des questions de sécurité de défense où
on modifie le traité mais on peut
manifester notre souci de trouver une
solution mais mais je sans doute que je
manque et que nous manquons
d'imagination mais comment on fait pour
régler cette contradiction
de 13 à bien appuyé sur ce problème la
vie de la Cour de justice
je prends une formule que ma président
de la Cour a utilisé la rentrée
solennelle elle a dit le juge applique
les traités c'est pas lui qui les
négocie ni lui qu'il est rédige je crois
que c'est ça je crois que là c'est parce
que c'est un problème politique
effectivement tu as un problème
politique
moi je vous ai dit à titre personnel que
je n'envisageais pas avec beaucoup
d'allant ni d'enthousiasme le fait que
la Cour européenne devienne une
juridiction de première instance est-ce
que ça dénature très son office
si ceux qui signent un traité décide
qu'il en va assis nous appliquerons mais
s'il décide que la Cour de justice doit
devenir compétente pour la place
donc je pense qu'à un moment on est fort
quand on reste sur son terrain
donc moi je reste sur le terrain d'une
juridiction la juridiction elle fait ce
que les États qui ont signé pour les
juridictions internationales en tout cas
c'est l'alpha et Oméga qui ont signé un
traité institutif de la juridiction lui
dit de faire pas plus pas moins donc je
pense que vous avez raison c'est
largement la coature du cercle mais de
l'imagination oui je pense qu'il peut y
en avoir de la volonté il en faudra
aussi parce que mais en tout cas je
pense pas que les juridictions
pourraient se débrouiller elle-même sans
réponse au niveau du traité
ou pour sortir de cette impasse en tout
cas on ne serait pas légitime à le faire
nous n'avons pas de titre à le faire
[Musique]
je n'en vois je n'en vois pas
d'ailleurs nous allons
bien écrit un article oui oui j'ai écrit
un article sur le les travaux
préparatoires oui oui j'ai créé un
article
dans une revue allemande goting
Gottingen low review en anglais oui oui
mais j'ai la version française aussi
voilà mais je peux vous envoyer la
version les deux celle que vous voulez
avec grand plaisir si vous voulez
merci beaucoup monsieur le juge pour
toutes ces
remarques qui ont été apportées par nos
collègues mais aussi vos réponses bien
sûr comme vous l'avez dit une délégation
se rendra à Strasbourg pour pour
rencontrer à nouveau d'ici là nous
aurons nous produits nos propres actes
parlementaires notamment au travers une
proposition de résolution européenne
dont nous allons voir le contenu à
l'issue de notre entretien sur justement
cette question d'adhésion de l'Union à
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme donc voilà
vous qui nous avez dit en préambule que
la vie parlementaire était pour vous
essentielle je pense que nous essaierons
n'ont pas de vous éclairer mais de vous
apporter des éléments de réflexion ici
au sein du Parlement sur cette question
et c'est d'ailleurs une question qui est
portée essentiellement par le Sénat
parce que voilà elle était elle a été
visée par le Sénat et portée par le
Sénat voilà avec avec des échanges à la
fois ministériels et même au plus haut
niveau de l'État sur cette question qui
qui ont le sens Titi nos institutions
le président de votre invitation de ces
échanges et je terminerai si vous me le
permettez en disant nous lisons toujours
les travaux parlementaires du Parlement
pas seulement ceux de la convention ça
nous éclaire parce que quand on doit
juger au plus près du respect de ce
qu'on voulut les États les travaux
parlementaires sont une source de
compréhension et d'inspiration nous
avons rendu à la demande du Conseil
d'État un avis consultatif sur le
retrait des accas des associations de
chasse comme dirait et on y a vous
découvrez des passages sur la déférence
vis-à-vis du Parlement et sur le la
prise en considération du soin mis dans
le processus parlementaire à auditionner
des gens et à discuter et pour nous dans
notre contrôle cette étape là de de la
ce que nous appelons nous la qualité de
la loi c'est-à-dire le soin mis par le
parlement national à appréhender les
enjeux à régler les points d'équilibre
est un paramètre que nous prenons en
considération au tout premier plan et je
suis heureux de le dire ici au Sénat
bien merci merci Monsieur le Juge je
vais vous raccompagner merci chers
collègues donc peuvent rester les
membres de la commission des affaires
européennes
je n'exclurai pas les membres de la
commission des lois mais on leur disant
que ils ne pourront pas participer au
vote bien sûr
d'un travail qu'on a déjà effectué
ensemble en commun préalablement